[Music]
very honored to have this chance to meet
uh and we've always had great
conversations and uh we'll have a lot of
important topics uh to discuss today I
was very disappointed I couldn't come uh
during these last four years uh and so
it's very exciting to be back
now that was Bill Gates less than a
month ago visiting his good pal XI
jinpin now she apparently returned the
favor by using the company that he
founded of course Gates founded
Microsoft
to launch a Cyber attack against the U.S
government
now despite the FED spending what 15.6
billion on cyber security more than the
GDP of nearly what 75 countries
Chinese cyberspies were able to exploit
a fundamental Gap in Microsoft's Cloud
enabling them to hack email accounts at
the state department and other agencies
but this really should come as no
surprise because Microsoft has had a
really symbiotic relationship for China
for years now
as Forbes noted in a recent piece in
2014 Microsoft became the first foreign
company to offer public Cloud Computing
Services in the Chinese market
and in March of this year
they would begin offering
um open AI as part of its uh cloud
services
and get this Microsoft gave the Chinese
government access to the source code for
its Windows operating system that
happened back in March of 2003.
joining me now Senator Tom Cotton who
sits on the Senate Intel and armed
services Community senator
our government relies on these tech
companies for its Communications
and of course these tech companies rely
on China for money
how is this a sustainable relationship
senator
well Laura it's not a relationship we
should be in with Chinese Communists or
that some of our leading companies
should be and as you said in the opening
this goes back Decades of failures of uh
trying to integrate our economy with
China's and you just saw the spectacle
of the Secretary of Treasury going to
China and cow Towing and saying that
people like you and I are wrong when we
say that we should decouple from China's
economy so we could eliminate all the
threats they pose to our safety and
health and our prosperity so I think
Microsoft has some answers to provide
here you know the reporting I've seen
suggests that you couldn't access these
accounts in the government just through
like an individual key but it would take
something the equivalent of what you
might call a master key and that should
have been secure at Microsoft and how
did Chinese Communists get their hands
on that but there's also a broader Point
here that goes beyond Microsoft and it
goes to our government to Joe Biden in
particular he continues to try to
accommodate conciliate and appease with
Xi Jinping and the Chinese Communists so
we shouldn't be surprised that they
continue to take these provocative steps
a few months ago sending a balloon to
float over China now it's hacking into
the state department yet what do we see
a continued flow of senior
Administration officials like the
Secretary of Treasury and soon it's
going to be John Kerry talking about
climate change going to China to plead
with China to help Joe Biden fill his
goals we shouldn't be surprised they're
continuing to taking more aggressive
provocative actions against us and our
friends now Senator cotton without
Republican votes
the Pentagon could not continue doing
what the Pentagon does and we all love
our military that goes without saying
but given the fact that our government
is clearly working to enrich China
and grow the Chinese economy
how do we keep asking taxpayers to fund
this Pentagon at this level we're
certainly not acting like a superpower
when China is about to build this Base
in Cuba and we apparently have nothing
to say about it so how do we ask the
taxpayers in good faith to keep working
over the money
well Laura what we need to do in the
Congress and what I'm trying to do with
others make sure that we're funding the
right things in the Pentagon the right
kind of weapon systems or the troop
levels that are going to help deter
China and deter their aggression whether
it's more submarines or modernizing our
nuclear forces or making sure that our
base is in the Western Pacific are
secure against China Chinese attacks
what we shouldn't be doing is funding
the lefts and the byte administration's
politicization of our military both in
the Senate the house we've taken some
steps to try to stop that I hope we can
continue to do more in the weeks ahead
as we consider the legislation in the
Congress but we need to be funding the
right things that are going to help our
troops deter Chinese aggression against
America's interests Senator cotton is
justice of Senator Schmidt of Missouri
last night I'm going to ask you the same
question do you think the military has
become a hostile work environment to
people of strong faith Catholics Muslims
Jewish Americans given the radical turn
on racial and gender indoctrination
so Laura I've heard anecdotes about that
some of them coming from people with
whom I served you know 15 or almost 20
years ago I guess I don't think it's
necessarily pervasive especially on the
front lines and the company and the
battalions and their babes but clearly
at the higher levels you have civilian
political appointees who are very
ideological who are trying to take steps
to politicize the military and to
socially engineer it that we should not
ever do with our military because
but do you think a devout Catholic would
be elevated
to become a general in today's military
like and a very you know outwardly
devout Catholic in this Administration
would be elevated to the general level
I do Laura and I think that's the case
at most levels as well I I don't I I
don't doubt though that there are some
ideologues of the Pentagon who are not
just focused on religion they're focused
on Race they're focused on sexuality
they're not focused on what's necessary
which is making sure our troops are
ready to fight when our nation's Wars
and hopefully therefore not having to
fight them in the first place yeah well
we have the Secretary of Navy who just
said in a in a major address at the
national Press Club that we are
completely outflanked on the naval Side
by China I mean they have what 50 more
ships than we have they have a much
bigger shipbuilding capacity than we
have and yet our trade policy seems to
be geared toward enriching China Senator
so when I when the angle is about you
know this doesn't make any sense that
doesn't make any sense to people who are
actually paying the bills here
yeah it's in part again because we have
been Outsourcing so much of our
industrial base to China for 20 or 30
years
um you know they've got shipyards that
can do all of what American shipyards
can do combined that's got to be a real
focus of ours I mean we cannot continue
to let China to crank out more ships in
a year than we can build in three or
four or five years that's all about
bringing jobs back to the United States
all about developing skilled workers
we're going to get high paying jobs in
places like our shipyards that are going
to be contributing to our National
Defense so Senator great to see you
thanks so much hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else